all right so as we talked about earlier
we just had the 20th anniversary of 9
11. uh we talked a little bit about the
george w bush speech on the 20th
anniversary um there were a number of
different events with multiple former
presidents commemorating
the 20-year anniversary of the 9 11
attacks i've told my story of where i
was on 9 11 many times i was sitting in
my morning psychology class in high
school and a known troublemaker came
back from wandering the halls and said
we're under attack and our teacher the
late great mr donald palmisano told him
you've caused enough trouble today i'm
sure everything's fine sit down and we
quickly learned not everything was fine
mr palmisano ended up apologizing to
that student when we were ultimately
back in class and said
you were right and i was wrong
um so on saturday the 20th anniversary
of 9 11 presidents biden obama bush and
clinton all attended and spoke at
various events and commemorations
trump didn't go to any of that stuff he
later stopped by ground zero sort of
close by and took some pictures with
firefighters
didn't go to the actual events
but what donald trump did do on the 20th
anniversary of 9 11
is boxing commentary
i'm not kidding
as i posted to twitter on saturday
tongue-in-cheek of course
a sober commemoration of 911
by a former president
this was promoted for a while
president trump hosts
the most anticipated
heavyweight fight of the year
on the 20th anniversary of 9 11.
holyfield versus belfort
i was shocked by this also since
holyfield's almost 60 years old i didn't
realize that this was so anticipated but
okay
and it was promoted as having full live
in-person commentary by president trump
apparently it was trump and donald trump
jr and
how many layers are there to this stuff
not only is a former president doing
boxing commentary on the 20th
anniversary of 9 11.
not only is he doing it with his doofus
son
but the son
even sort of turns it into a grift which
you'll hear in this clip take a look at
this we're here at hard rock in
florida
by the way the audio is all you just you
can barely even hear
a trump great night with a lot of great
champions
to them they're going to be having a
good time i wouldn't want to do it a lot
of people wouldn't want to do it but
they look like they're going to have a
good time i just saw a couple of the
fighters the desperation from don jr to
be liked by his dad and the stupid
forced laughs at every dumb joke it's
almost sad they love doing this stuff so
we're going to watch evander and detour
we're going to watch anderson silva
right
oh
guys i think this is going to be a lot
of levity at the end of a rather somber
day have a little bit of a somber levity
at the end of a summer day don't forget
to shoot me your questions i may have to
finally twist his arm a little bit to
find out about area 51 and the aliens or
whatever else you may want to ask about
you know what this is he he was doing
this grift all day don jr this was a
pay-per-view event and so don jr was
teasing you know
i'm i'm gonna take questions and maybe
some of the questions will be about the
truth about aliens what does trump know
about aliens because he's the president
and he was told all sorts of stuff
it's all a grift in the end they will do
anything for a buck and or for publicity
we're gonna have some fun at the end of
a somber day and i'm just looking
forward to it some of the great fight
legends are here guys you can check it
out on any cable network or fight tv
tune in now
yeah
um it it's just nothing there's nothing
that isn't a grift with these people
um
let's look at some of the actual
commentary just to be thorough and it's
like then they start explaining to trump
sir people are chanting your name and
it's just oh so weird this was the 20th
anniversary of 911
there's a former president okay if obama
had done boxing commentary on the 20th
anniversary of 9 11 it would be 24 7
coverage for three days on fox news
about how anti-american obama is
here we go that was a fantastic job by a
really great young man
he's got a big future and
we're just honored
thank you
that's what everybody's saying
i don't think i hear that back home
everybody's screaming right now
[Applause]
do you think trump's at all embarrassed
that where he's going now for this is
where he's doing boxing commentary like
this is the stage on which he now
appears
thank you very much what an amazing
rendition of the national anthem
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody thank you
this is an honor to be with you and what
a great evening and
i think you're going to see an
incredible fight and
jorge it's great junior it's great to be
with you guys and uh champions we love
you man special people special warriors
[Applause]
i don't feel i feel like i live in a
different country than where this
environment is going on like it's almost
surreal that this is where
this is what one former president was
doing on 9 11.
we're still going strong
[Applause]
that's good
they got the chat going that's been
going around stadiums in the college
football for the last couple of days
there's don jr
is there something sad and pathetic
about don jr having to come in and say
yeah yep this is the same chant that all
the sto the the people in stadiums have
been doing
it's a degree of please love me dad that
actually makes me sad for don jr in a
way
well it's a great honor and thank you
very much thank you everybody very much
we love our country i love our country
thank you very much
so we're going to see a great fight
tonight and uh we've seen some good ones
that last one we're going to call it i
think it's going to be a short one you
think it's going to be well you've been
calling them very accurately i think
this is going to be a short one then
you're right because
future is very explosive yes she is it's
always uh
crap
are they even at the venue like it
almost seems like trump's not even at
the venue it's something about this is
all very weird and and two warriors
very exciting isn't it huh
very exciting no two great fighters
one's a boxer though the others uh
mma
yeah all right so there's trump's
analysis there uh this is just
embarrassing and again the world's
laughing at all of it and uh it's just
what are people thinking what are people
thinking one other little aspect of this
that i did want to touch on which starts
to actually go over the line into the
politically absurd and let's talk about
that next
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
that focuses exclusively on
documentaries if you love documentaries
the way i do you're missing out if you
don't have a subscription to curiosity
stream i love it for one reason it has
the biggest best selection of
documentaries that you'll find anywhere
including the newest popular ones that
everybody's talking about and most of it
is stuff you really can't find on other
streaming services last month they added
a ton of great new documentaries to the
library one i watched is brimstone and
glory
about a pyrotechnic festival in mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 off meaning you
can subscribe for just 15 bucks a year
not a big price tag relative to the
hours and hours of enjoyment i know you
will get from curiositystream
just go to
curiositystream.com pacman the link is
right underneath this video